Oh everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast development of selection
strategies for homologous recombination
deficient hrd patients utilizing a
liquid biopsy i'm robert assalamu collab
roots and i'll via moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by epic sciences
ethic sciences enter the privately-held
diagnostics company that is developing
highly sensitive test to identify the
molecular characterized circulating
tumor cells ctcs who are minimally
invasive blood sample we've developed a
powerful rare cell detection and
characterization platform which was
founded on unique technology exclusively
licensed from the scripps research
institute this unbiased and enrichment
free approach will empower the
personalization and monitoring of cancer
treatments our partners include more
than 37 pharmaceutical and biotechnology
companies major cancer centers the
National Center the National Cancer
Institute the Institute of Health these
collaborations use epic sciences class
12 operationally monitor changes in the
composition of CDC's during the course
of study furthermore our no cell left
behind technology can help manage
patients to the right therapies and
monitors for drug resistance so that the
best treatment path can be chosen at
every clinical decision point for more
information please visit epic scientist
calm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window or try to answer
as many questions as we can we can
enlarge the slide window by clicking on
the screen icon and the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if
technical problems here in this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the C button
located in the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
of containing your credits I want to
introduce today's speaker mark lenders
mark lenders has 20 years of experience
developing and commercializing molecular
safe to drive translational and clinical
research in his current position as VP
of translational research a tactic
scientists including the development of
a safe to characterize CDC by genotype
and phenotype at the single-cell level
these are saved can be utilized to build
clinical tests to drive patient care
decisions prior to his tenure at epic
sciences mark was head of R&D Althea DX
where he's developed several campaign
estate for targeted therapies he has
also held several senior level scientist
positions in the san diego bio tech
community companies including Life
Technologies Co gene and Baikal I'll now
turn it over to mark landers for his
presentation thanks Robert and thanks to
everybody who logged in this morning for
the talk so the focus of the talk is on
detection of hrd and CTCs in it from
metastatic castrate-resistant prostate
cancer patients using the epic liquid
biopsy but before we get started into a
detection of hrd I'll give a little
background on the epic CTC platform how
it works why it's different and then
focus on how we've leveraged that
platform to develop predictive tests
that really can answer key clinical
questions at clinical decision points
but oncologist face then we'll focus on
detection of HR thrd and cpcs and how we
can you see hrd in CT
these then how we've used a phenotypic
signature to predict hrd genomics and
then finally how we can use that
phenotypic signature to predict hrd as
well as predict response to park
inhibitors and so first a little
background on epic sciences so I think
there were some mentioned in the intro
we were in 2008 we were spun out of the
scripps research institute and we're
currently located in a 40,000 square
foot facility in San Diego that's shown
in the lower left-hand panel we r kappa
credited clia-certified and currently
support over 90 clinical trials this is
with our 40 or so Pharma partners or 25
x + 25 academic partners we've developed
capabilities that allow us to run our CT
csa but we also have integrated
capabilities which will describe further
that include DNA fish qpcr and single
cell NGS and so we'll dive a little bit
into the capabilities as we go through
the background and so I'm going to focus
a little bit on on the epic platform and
how it works and so traditionally since
they're just since the discovery of ctcs
in the 1800's there's been a lot of ways
to try to isolate CTCs from the blood
and so as as people have developed
different approaches they've either
targeted surface markers like f cam or
they've tried to use the differences in
size between the tumor cells in the
white blood cells to filter out CTCs or
changes in density all of these
approaches though require that you know
something about what a tumor cell looks
like or is and so the key difference
with the epic platform is that we are
taking all nucleated cells from a blood
draw no enrichment no selection so this
really allows us to see a much wider
biological range of cpcs from a single
drop and so I walk through how it works
so at a clinical site a simple
peripheral blood draw this is taken it's
a 10 mil tube so we get about eight
mills of blood in there it's room
temperature shipment to one of three
sites so we have a in North America we
ask that you ship the samples to our
site in San Diego for European trials we
have a relationship with LabCorp which
allows to ship samples to Belgium and
then we also have a site in Singapore
which can handle the asia-pacific trials
basically once blood is drawn samples
are received that within 72 hours of
blood draw we like to process the
samples we can process them up to 96
hours but preferably best performance is
72 hours post blood drop so once the
samples received red blood cells are
lysed and all nucleated cells are spun
down into a pellet these cells are then
resuspended and deposited onto the
surface of glass slides typically from a
single tube we make about 10 slides and
so these can then be either frozen away
or assayed immediately and so we have
data showing that these are quite stable
once frozen so I think we have a
stability study out to two years and so
typically two slides are assayed / assay
and that means that you have we create a
little bio bank from each sample so
those can be stored in the freezer which
is really useful for when you want to
look at additional markers later or
bridging studies so the assay to look
for CDC's is an if' staining assay and
so this consists of a cocktail of
antibodies directed towards different
side of keratins that help us identify
epithelial cells an antibody against
cd45 which helps
line up the white blood cells dappy
which characterizes the nuclear staining
so tells us what cells have intact
nuclei and then we have additional room
for additional markers and so in this
case the biomarker and for most of the
data will be showing you will be AR or
an AR isoform and so typically we also
have assays for breast cancer the target
ER or CMAC we can there's a lot of
things we can target there and so we do
we have a menu of test items as well as
we doing that custom assay development
so after the iif staining procedure each
slide is scanned and so this takes about
five minutes per channel each slide so
we're scanning over three million cells
per slide collecting data are not only
the if' fluorescence intensities but
also on cell morphology and so really
then what does the heavy lifting here is
the proprietary algorithm and this is
looking at the cells on the surface of
the slide the way a pathologist would so
it includes not only the cytokeratin
expression cd45 but also looking at the
morphological features of the cell and
so from that skip that algorithm we
generate a list of candidates epc's
those CTCs are then confirmed by trained
pathologist trained staff and then we
have a list of ctcs and can enumerate
and characterize them further and so
when I talked about a wider biological
range of ctcs that we see this is this
is what we're talking about and so the
upper left panel is showing what if the
surface of a slide looks like and so
mostly what you're seeing their white
blood cells so typically we can see we
know what white blood cells look like
and then we can look for rare events and
so the what's shown below that are what
we call classic or typical CDC's and
these are much larger than this year
bounding white blood cells and have a
brighter cytokeratin expression these
are what we call classic CTC so but
what's more important than that or what
is important as well are that those
shown on the right where we see small
CTCs that other platforms might miss we
can see a pop tonic CTCs where we see
they no longer have an intact nuclei but
can characterize the expression of
different biomarkers on the surface EMT
type cells where we no longer have that
they're typically epithelial plastic the
cytokeratins are not very bright or not
expressed at all but we know that these
are still expressing our biomarker of
interest or have morphology consistent
with a CPC we could also see CTCs and
clusters and any of these subclasses of
ctcs and clusters and so one of the
questions were commonly asked as well
well what does that mean and why is it
detecting more CTCs better and so we did
a head-to-head comparison and this is
work done in conjunction with Memorial
sloan-kettering and this is a
head-to-head comparison for self search
and so metastatic castrate-resistant
prostate cancer patients were a blood
drive was taken prior to treatment with
either abiraterone enzalutamide or
taxane in a first line second line or
third line saying a replicate sample was
taken for cell search analysis and then
the hero we're simply doing is comparing
how many CTCs we saw at that particular
blood drawn so this is data from 173
patient samples and so the top panel is
showing the CTCs per mil detected by
epic and that's shown in the blue bars
the red bars show the ctc is detected by
the self search platform right below
that are is the diff
and so you can see typically where you
see all the blue bars that's where is
epic detected more CTCs than the cell
search platform and even more critical
to that as the clinical sensitivity and
so how many patients did we see with
CTCs or we could then go on and
characterize different biomarkers on Oct
cs and if you look at the table on the
bottom from the hundred and seventy
three patients that we looked at with
cell search CTCs were present in
sixty-seven percent across all lines of
therapy whereas with the epic platform
we detected CTCs and over ninety six
percent of the patients tested so much
better clinical specialist sensitivity
and then when you ask the question of
why those are these CTC subtypes that
other platforms are missing are they
important what we did is we looked at
okay if a patient had a prevalence of
these CTC subtypes what did that mean
how do those patients do in comparison
to other patients were they biologically
meaningful and so shown on top our
patients who had a prevalence of
cytokeratin negative or epithelial
plastic CTCs and and how they did in
comparison to other patients within the
cohort and so that's shown on the red
line of that kaplan-meier curve and the
significance of that is shown over on
the right in the multivariate model
where you see the red p value and so it
was it was significant that these
patients did much worse if they had a
prevalence of CK negative CTCs and even
more drastic with the prevalence of
small CTCs and so you can see a dramatic
difference in overall survival so these
different subtypes are lead to much
worse prognosis for these patients and
so beyond enumeration we've done a lot
of work to integrate in downstream
technologies that can really help us
characterize the CTCs at a much more
detailed level and that's really it will
be some of the tools we use today when
we talk
how we've leveraged the platform we use
a lot of these tools and so beyond just
care identifying the CTCs and enumerate
them we have a variety of protein
markers which are very useful but beyond
just expression of those different
proteins we can also characterize the
localization of it and as I'll show you
later in nuclear localization of
particular like the ARV seven marker is
critical to defining the clinical
specificity we've also integrated in
capabilities like DNA fish where we can
remove the cover slip at fish probes
after staining and now we're integrating
genotype and phenotype information as
part of the process we're also
collecting XY coordinates from each cell
and this allows us to pick single cells
off the surface of the slide and then do
downstream qpcr and next-gen sequencing
and we'll show you some data from that
today and so now i'm going to focus a
little bit more less on the platform but
more on how we've developed predictive
tests leveraging this platform and so we
want to develop tests that answer
specific clinical questions in an
oncologist might face and so when you
when one of the first questions we
sought to answer was in metastatic
castrate-resistant prostate cancer
patients often get abiraterone
enzalutamide or a are targeted therapies
or they're they're put on taxanes or
cytotoxic chemotherapy the question is
which patients would respond better to
which therapy and when to give which
therapy and so work we did that was
published earlier this year and this is
work with ms k and howard shears group
and so the interesting part here is that
this is targeting a rv7 so that air b7
is a truncated version
androgen receptor it's missing plugin
binding domain is constitutively active
and it's been shown that expression of
air should be seven has been associated
with resistance to air turn in therapy
and so we looked at of the patients we
looked at here and so this is showing
you patients with a prevalence of a rv7
expressed and localized to the nucleus
showed when given a are targeted
therapies had very good specificity and
was only detected in patients who had
PSA response of PSA progression and
that's shown in the upper left panel
where all the dots that you see that are
where we detected air v7 those were all
in patients who had PSA progression when
given an AR targeted therapy more
dramatic than that is if you look over
on the far right panel is when you gave
these patients are targeted therapy and
those are that AR v7 positive patients
are shown on the red line of these km
curves these patients did much worse
they had a hazard ratio of 11.45 when
given the AR targeted therapy so clearly
not a good choice there a farah p4 these
patients but what we wanted to
understand better is how much better
these patients did when you gave them a
taxing chemotherapy and so shown below
is the therapy interaction that we were
able to demonstrate and so when these
patients who are a rv7 positive were
given a taxane instead of given an AR
targeted therapy we showed it that there
hazard ratio was reduced to point two
four and so this is a seventy six
percent reduction in risk for these
patients so this is a very good
predictive test and can be used in a
second first or second line third line
setting to identify patients who should
not be given a brad around and salute
amide or other era targeted therapies
and should be switched to taxing
chemotherapies and so one of the in the
same clinical setting
we really wanted to understand because
as we looked at these patient samples we
saw a wide variety of ctc subtypes it's
really in metastatic castrate-resistant
prostate cancer it's a lot like the wild
less you see a lot of different crazy
cell types in these patients so what we
really wanted to understand is when is
disease heterogeneity so high that no
targeted therapy will work and you
should really be using the tax and
chemotherapy and so we looked at 221
patient samples about over 9,000 single
CTCs from these patients and we and we
thought to answer the question of what
is high heterogeneity and what's its
effect on being treated with either the
targeted therapy or chemotherapy and so
the way we did this was was following
the typical scanning procedure we did
high high content image analysis and so
basically this is doing a lot of
segmentation of the cells the nuclei of
cells and then we're able to measure a
lot of digital pathology features and so
the things we can measure in addition to
the if' expression at different markers
were nuclear area and nuclear to
cytoplasmic ratios circularity about 30
different measurements in total and so
we're doing this for each cell on the
surface of the slide from those features
we then use principal component analysis
to to mathematically come up with a
model for how many of these features
clustered together and made unique cell
types and so based on that analysis we
were able to come up with 15 different
CTC phenotypes that were present across
the entire cohort and so the what was
interesting there and what's shown on
the left is the prevalence of these CTC
subtypes labeled a through o across the
entire cohort and so this is in both
looking at how the prevalence of each
CTC subtype but what's more interesting
is when you look at the patient level
and so that the heat map shown here is
starting from the left to right p
each column represents a patient each
row represents a different subtype where
you see color and the darker the red
that's the the higher prevalence of that
particular CPC subtype and so the
patients with more CTC subtypes but it
is correlated to bigger diversity and so
as you see was we moved from first line
to fourth line you see that the
prevalence of multiple subtypes with
impatience got higher and so we wanted
to measure this and so we applied a
measurement called the Shannon index and
this is a diversity measure it's
commonly used by colleges when they got
to a new environment and they want to
characterize the diversity that they see
within like a rain forest they would
count up the different species that are
present and then based on that you can
score the the increase in diversity and
so that's what we applied here treating
the cell types as different species and
so when you look at the bar chart on the
right you can see that the Shannon index
as it as diversity increases the number
increases all the way up to over two and
so in the first line we saw
heterogeneity but we did see
heterogeneity increases you move from
first to fourth line but was
particularly interesting to us was that
we saw very high heterogeneity and first
line patients and we also saw very low
heterogeneity and fourth line patients
and so it became really apparent test
that these different CTC subtypes could
be very critical to characterize further
before I get to that I'll show you what
the effect of a different heterogeneity
score is and so we took the top 25% of
the patients from by Shannon index so
the patients with the highest
heterogeneity and looked how well they
did when they were given a are targeted
therapy or when they were given taxing
chemotherapy and so when you look at the
cam curves
the top that's showing on the Left
progression-free survival and on right
the overall survival of these patients
and you can see that on when these
patients with very heterogeneous disease
were given a are targeted therapies they
had a hazard ratio of 5.5 however when
they were given the taxing chemotherapy
data hazard ratio of 1.6 them they did
much better on taxanes in comparison to
the AR targeted therapy and so again we
look to show the therapy interaction
that these patients with high
heterogeneity when given the taxing
chemotherapies had a reduction in risk
and so here we saw their hazard ratios
when given the tax and chemotherapy
their hazard ratios were reduced to 0
point 3 2 3 and so there's a significant
reduction in risk when you take these
patients with high disease heterogeneity
and give them a cytotoxic chemotherapy
versus they are targeted therapy and so
beyond that we as I said we were
characterizing all these different CTCs
and CTC subtypes we were able to do
incorporate our single cell sequencing
to look for the clone allottee of these
look for different drivers that were
driving different subclones and look how
those subclones did across the course of
treatment and so this is showing CTCs
from a single patient and so you can see
there were eight CTCs detected in this
patient that had very flat genomes that
what's shown here are whole genome copy
numbers each dot represents a 1 million
base pair window in the genome and where
you see the dot above the zero bar
that's an amplification where you see it
below that's a deletion and what was
interesting is that you can see
different clonal species with different
genomics and so you can see the five
patients on the on the middle bottom
right there who had a are amplification
but there were also patients that had
unstable genomes where we actually saw
that they didn't have an errand
vacation so we actually saw a branching
event there and the reason this is
important is we actually found
particular CTC subtypes that didn't do
well on it either type therapy and so
this is important to what we're going to
talk about today but this cell type k
and this was presented by her chair at
ASCO gu earlier this year there was a
particular CTC subtype this was had
large nucleus high nuclear entropy
nucleus of nucleoli and when you had a
prevalence of these type of cells these
patients did particularly poor on air
targeted therapies but also didn't do
very well on the taxane chemotherapies
when we pixton sequenced these cells we
saw that they had a high prevalence of
genomic scarring consistent with what
you'd find it in hrd and so these
patients had a higher prevalence of
large-scale transitions and we'll get
into this a little further but this
really was the what made us think that
we could particularly characterize hrd
using morphological measures and so I
think that this is where we're going to
we're going to dive a little bit into
hrd and and parp inhibitors and how hrd
is predictive of parp inhibitors so
after setting the stage I think I'll
take a step back and characterize and
provide background information on how
harp inhibitors work how people are out
there measuring hrd and then how this
test is different and what the
advantages and disadvantages are and so
the mechanism of action for parp
inhibitors basically target the single
strand repair pathway and so parp
inhibitors are targeting car park can no
longer participate in the base excision
repair pathway you accumulate a lot of
single strand breaks and you're unable
to fix those which then lead to double
strand breaks in a normal cell the
accumulation of double
train brakes is repaired by the
homologous recombination pathway with
very high fidelity in patients who have
a mutation in this pathway are unable to
fix their DNA you get a double strand
DNA repair by the non-homologous end
joining pathway which is much lower foot
fidelity and leads to much more unstable
genomes and so parp inhibitors are
particularly effective in the patients
that have homologous recombination
deficiency big question is how do you
find these patients and so traditionally
people have looked at a variety of
genomic markers and so there's been a
lot of work published showing that
bracket mutations in the germline in
ovarian are often associated with hrd
when you expand that pathway out into to
including ATM palvi to other pathway
members and look in somatic look for
somatic vince and tissue biopsy that
number increases to roughly twenty
percent and then others have been looked
for marks of genomic scarring and i
think we showed some of this earlier but
they look for large-scale transitions
allelic imbalance or loss of
heterozygosity and the advantage to this
is you're actually looking for the
effect of HR deficiency on the DNA so
the caveat to the all the tests on this
border their genomic based test so that
it requires interpretation of the
variants you have to understand the
impact of the variant with the allelic
frequency cut-offs when you're looking
in tissue and then you also have to be
able to set cutoff and interpret these
they're all dependent on in the somatic
setting at least on on biopsy and it we
think that there's there's considerable
issues with biopsy in the metastatic
setting and then all of these because
they're sequencing-based tasks have much
turn around times and so thinking about
what's out there and the current methods
that have been used to characterize hrd
our thought process was that we wanted
to develop a test that could be run from
a simple blood drop that would provide
single-cell resolution that could allow
us to better understand the
heterogeneity that's present in a
patient but could also detect somatic HR
DISA sub clonal hrd patients that are
have a sub clone that has hrd but maybe
not the entirely germline disease state
we wanted to develop a test that was non
sequencing-based that could be performed
in a week had lower cogs and equivalent
or better performance to the current
methods that are out there but more
importantly and I'll show you the data
from what we've generated today is we
wanted to be able to answer specific
clinical question and direct treatment
and so I think that's what we're going
to focus on today is how we've applied
this to metastatic castrate-resistant
prostate cancer so as we move along that
will be the data that we focus on and so
we started out by saying you know we
understand how tissue sequencing is done
and the markers there's been a lot of
publications showing tissue sequencing
so the first question we wanted to
address is could we see genomic markers
of hrd in our CTCs and so this is really
data where we just we picked in sequence
etc's and and what's shown here are a
hold of genome copy number of plots of
individual CTCs and so again i'll walk
through the process where post staining
we remove the coverslip we had some some
buffer to help us recover the cells from
the surface of the slide and then using
a micromanipulator type instrument it
drives to the exact XY coordinates
recovers the cell from the surface of
the slide and transfers it to a single
well of a 96-well plate the cells are
lysed whole genome amplified and then
sequenced and the data we're showing
here right now is from low-pass whole
genome
seen then we can generate whole genome
copy number profile similar to what you
would see in an array CGH experiment and
then we can look for not only focal
amplifications and deletions but the
presence of large-scale transitions so
areas of greater than 10 mega base that
are either amplified or deleted this
scores as one LST and so it's shown here
when we characterize the number of LSTs
/ CTC you can see an example of that on
top where the single CTC from a breca
mutant patient had 45 LST and a single
CTC from a breca wild-type patient had
very few of so we went back to some of
the classic models for harp sensitivity
and so there's been a lot of work
published that has characterized genomic
scarring and triple negative breast
cancer and ovarian and so we took some
triple negative breast cancer cell lines
and then we spiked them into the system
they were spiked into healthy donor
blood we picked and sequenced these
cells and we looked for the presence of
genomic scars and so the two cell lines
that are shown on the outside columns
but hcc 1 365 days as well as mb 231 to
be our control and MV 436 so the two on
the outside NB 436 and hcc 1365 these
are our perp sensitive Braca mutant cell
lines and then the one in the middle is
our triple negative breast cancer cell
line which we know has a high degree of
genomic instability but is part
insensitive and so the idea here is that
we would measure genomic scarring in the
single cell level and then we would see
how can we best separate typical genomic
instability that we would expect to see
from hrd levels of genomic and
ability and so what's shown on the far
left are the number of LSD is detected
in single cells shown in blue versus a
control sample which is just both DNA
from that same cell line and so you can
see first that we can recapitulate the
number of large-scale transitions we see
per single ctc very well in comparison
to the the bulk control but when we
compared that to the number of LOH
breakpoints we got by doing whole exome
sequencing from single cells as well as
the selling controls we saw that the
measurement of LSPs really separate
these two high genomic instability part
insensitive from high genomic
instability PARP sensitive and so this
is that what we used moving forward to
train our phenotypic classifier for hrd
and a lot of questions are always asked
about how this relates back to tissue
breka status and so we sequence a lot of
patient samples here and what this is
showing is each column represents CTCs
from a single patient and that we're
characterizing the number of LSTs per
patient and the far left panel shows the
patients in which we have a match tissue
biopsy that had a breakout ATM mutation
and the panel and right in the middle
shows the patients in which we had a
brac ratm wild-type tissue biopsy and so
it's interesting here as you can see
that there's a much higher prevalence of
LSTs in the patients in which there was
breca or ATM mutations present in the
tissue biopsy but we also see hrd in the
wild-type patients in very sub clonal
populations and so this is the far right
panel showing patience in which we were
unable to get coverage of the entire
region so we couldn't make a wild-type
or mutant status because there were
holes in the coverage or we detected
mutations that we didn't know the
significance of
and so clearly you can see high degrees
of hrd in these patients in which we
were unable to select my tissue
sequencing and so once we were we were
pretty confident at that we were able to
see CPC or hrd genomics NRC TCS we
wanted to train up our our phenotypic
classifier that could then be used to
predict that level of hrd genomics and
so to do that we followed the same
methods that we use when we were looking
at heterogeneity and so starting with
patients single CTCs from patients where
we knew in their tissue biopsy they had
brachyura ATM mutations we picked and
sequenced the CDC's from those patients
and characterized the number of LSTs and
then we did the high content image
analysis for each of those cells and so
the idea here is that we're going to be
able to compare genotype to phenotype at
the single-cell level and different
patient populations either ARB
recommendations and so when we did this
we collected all of our phenotypic
features and we saw some of the
phenotypic features and that correlated
very strongly to the presence of genomic
scarring and specifically of lfts and
shown on the left is a panel showing
some of these genomic features that we
measure and their correlation to an
increasing number of LSTs and then when
you look over on the panel of the right
these are showing the
features ranked from top to bottom high
either positive correlation or negative
correlation to the presence of scarring
so then we can train up a model that
using these features and do a lot of
machine learning that will allow us to
look at phenotypes and predict genotypes
and so just taking a forty thousand foot
aerial view of what this looks like so
these are when we do that and we create
a model that predicts phenotypic using
just phenotypic measures to predict HIV
and then we go in and we we're looking
at the overall genomic instability that
we see in those cells so moving from
left to right on this heat map are
higher phenotypic hrd scores to lower
HRT's phenotypic hrd scores what's shown
on each row are particular genes and the
copy number variations we saw in those
jeans red being amplified green being
deleted and you can just see from from a
high-level view on the far left where we
saw and predicted high hrd using the
phenotype we also saw much higher
prevalence of copy number variation and
as we moved to the right we saw much
lower prevalence a copy number variation
in those CTCs but one of those cells
look like and so this is really
interesting when you see the cells have
a particular phenotype and the panel on
the Left shows a lot of images from hrd
positive ctcs that had so high
prevalence when we picked them in
sequence to handle hada LSTs and and
some of the common features shown here
are that they have low accent
eccentricity high nuclear to cytoplasmic
ratios and ended hi nuclear texture and
so this is equivalent to what you'd see
in like a black-and-white television
where we saw that there wasn't a very
uniform even Dappy staining procedure in
comparison to the cells that were
predicted down low genomic and
in which there was much higher
eccentricity lower or normal nuclear to
cytoplasmic ratios and normal nuclear
texture and so that then we moved on to
to train Lee and test the classifier and
so to do that we took close to 600
individual cells across 35 patients and
we picked in sequenced each cell
individually and looked for the presence
of LSTs and that's what's referred to
here as a LST and we compare that to
doing the high content image analysis
for each of those cells and using the
phenotypic measures to predict if it
would have high or low LSTs and so it's
shown here is in that in the 2 by 2
matrix is where we predicted that it
would have high LSTs by phenotype we saw
high prevalence that it did in fact have
high levels of genomic scarring and so
the accuracy at the single-cell level
was seventy eight percent we saw a very
good specificity we had eighty-six
percent specificity and where it got
even better was when we said okay in a
patient level we required there to be
three or more CTCs with this particular
phenotype how well did that match up to
there being a prevalence of three or
more CTCs with high genomic instability
is measured by sequencing and so the
median of these values is shown below
and the waterfall plot where we had high
levels of measured sequenced genomic
scarring versus the predicted genomic
scarring that we saw in it within an
entire patient and that's shown in blue
and so the patient level the classifier
gets even more specific and more
accurate and so I think we've walked
through how we do the CTC phenotypic
characterization how that correlates to
hrg genomics how those CTC genomics
correlate back to hrd mutations and the
biopsy sample
but really more importantly we wanted to
better understand what is the prevalence
of these hrd positive ctcs mean when
you're looking at patients and does it
predict response to therapy and so one
of the first questions we asked is okay
well what's the prevalence of this
marker across cohorts of mcrpc and what
does it mean when those patients are
given the standard of care therapies
would they be better on a PARP inhibitor
and so we took cells this is looking at
at 6,000 CTCs from close to 200 patient
samples where we now we've trained the
classifier now we've only done the
phenotypic analysis here and we saw
patients that were positive for the hrd
CTCs by phenotype we saw in the first
line twenty one percent in the second
line twenty four percent and up to forty
percent in the third line of therapy
across all lines of therapy about thirty
percent prevalence of the CTC based
marker using just imaging what was
interesting to us is we really wanted to
understand how do these patients do when
you gave them the AR targeted therapy in
comparison to the taxing or in
comparison to potentially a PARP
inhibitor so when given the standard of
care treatment options these patients
did much worse and so you can see the
patients on the red line of this km
curve were given the AR targeted therapy
those are the hrd positive patients and
they had a hazard ratio of close to 7.7
when given they are targeted therapy and
when given they did slightly better on
taxanes but still did worse than
patients without a charging and so these
were similar to what we saw with our
cell type k and these might be the
patients that you'd want to give the
parp inhibitor to and so to investigate
this further working with Felix Fang and
and the team running the NCI 9012 trial
we collected samples from
an included apartment hitter and so to
give you the trial design here patients
these are first-line metastatic
castrate-resistant prostate cancer
patients prior to treatment with either
abiraterone or abiraterone plus belapur
abbr the abbey parp inhibitor we
collected a baseline sample and then we
collected a non therapy sample we put
these samples on slides and then we
analyzed these slides for the presence
of hrd positive CTCs and then we look to
see if you had a prevalence of the
CFTC's could we predict your response to
two PARP inhibitors and so what's
important to understand when you look at
this trial in the first line setting the
a arm patients had virtually no
difference or no benefit in comparison
to patients given the parp inhibitor and
so you can see by the cam curves here
there wasn't any real benefit and mixing
in the parp inhibitor unless you used a
selection device and so i'll dive deeper
into the response here but what's
interesting is we saw the prevalence of
the biomarker in thirty percent roughly
thirty percent of patients that we lived
in so this matches up very well with the
other cohorts that we've seen from ms k
and now has been confirmed in multiple
additional cohorts as well we're seeing
the prevalence in metastatic
castrate-resistant patients across all
lines up there in about thirty percent
what was impressive to us as if you look
at these waterfall plots shown in the
bottom left these are showing the max
PSA decrease that we saw in each patient
sample where you see red bars you're
seeing our biomarker positive patients
and where you see blue bars you're
seeing our biomarker negative patients
what's important to consider here is
where we
cct sees those patients were scored as
biomarker negative we only counted a
patient as biomarker positive if they
had CT sees present and they had our hrd
phenotype and so it's shown in what's
interesting is that in the a.m where we
had where we treated with only the
labrum our biomarker positive patients
showed a PSA response only twenty-two
percent of them responded when you look
in our be arm where we actually if we
were to use our biomarker positive
patients ninety-three percent of our
biomarker positive patients showed a PSA
max penis a response and then across in
the biomarker negative patients did
about the same across both arms but was
interesting and then we looked over at
the overall survival of these patients
we saw that biomarker positive patients
did better and so when you look on the
cam curve shown on the left these this
is with no selection device we saw about
equal response of patients whether they
were given the parp inhibitor or not
when you look at with selecting patients
with our CPC classifier you can see
those km curves start to separate and so
this is very encouraging to us I think
with more n will actually see that get
to statistical significance fairly
quickly but what we also wanted to do is
confirm that we we were actually
targeting the cells we thought we were
and so we looked at using our
longitudinal draws we actually looked at
the prevalence of hrd positive CTCs from
the change in the prevalence of those
CTCs from baseline to on therapy and so
when we look at the Aon you can see
these patients were given only
abiraterone when there was a prevalence
of hrd positive CTCs at baseline we saw
one hundred and sixty-six percent
increase in a chair d+ CTCs on therapy
in contrast when you look at patients in
the be armed
there were 17 or we thought we saw a
dramatic decrease in HIV positive CTCs
after therapy so we were targeting the
cells we thought we were and so we saw
eighty-two percent reduction in the
prevalence of HIV positive CDC's when
you included the parp inhibitor and so
that's another validation that tells us
yes we can predict response to parp
inhibitors and then we can look
longitudinally to say yes in fact we are
getting the cells we thought we were
getting and so I wrap up at this point
and just some summary ideas is that you
know because of the wider biological
range of ctcs that were able to detect
the ck minus is small CTCs and the
integrated technologies that we use to
better characterize these CTCs both
genomically as well as phenotypically we
can develop predictive test that answer
key clinical questions such as the ARB 7
heterogeneity and now response to parp
inhibitors heterogeneity has a huge
impact on these tests and so I think
single-cell resolution is going to be
key to really identifying sub clonal
somatic tumor types and monitor their
progression throughout treatment and and
we were able to demonstrate that we
could in fact do that with our hrd
signature and in response to parp
inhibitors and so I wanted to also say
thanks to a lot of the work that was
done here with in conjunction with
collaborators and so the team at msk and
Howard cheers team in the NCI trial and
Felix paying and maja sane and all those
who helped us get those clinical samples
and then the epic team here who's really
driven this from ctc to actually
developing a predictive tests that can
be useful to directory and so I think we
have ten minutes left here and I think
this is where we
open it up to questions so I think back
to you Robert for any other questions no
no thank you so very much for your
wonderful presentation and before we get
started on the question answer session I
would like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions I'm typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on a
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we're going to
try and answer as many questions as we
possibly can and all questions that are
not answered will be followed up with at
a later time question number one
currently most CA RP trials require
screening for BRCA and 18 invitations
can you comment on how this test fit
into the landscape yeah and I think that
was one of the hopefully I highlighted
that during the talk but but one of the
key differentiators of this test is that
we're not we're not reliant on a fresh
biopsy and so and when you think about
metastatic castrate-resistant prostate
cancer and the lack of being able to get
a biopsy and the expense incurred in
taking a biopsy obviously the liquid
biopsy has a lot of advantages and in
many case taking a biopsy is dead
there's just it's unavailable or it
almost unethical to to do to these
patients and late-stage metastatic
disease um the test is is not
sequencing-based so you know I think
this is a key differentiator when you
think about how we take this test and
and have a quicker turnaround time as
well as globally deploy this and its
application as a diagnostic this test
has key advantages over sequencing in
the fact that that a lot of labs around
the world can do and
I have stained and and so simple blood
draw we can enable longitudinal
monitoring and so those are the key
differentiating factors so I see this
fitting into the landscape that we're
able to differentiate by addressing some
of the complications associated with
finding hrd and metastatic disease thank
you how does the prevalence of cr.pc hrd
positive patient in your study compared
to those of the top heart study yeah
that's a great question the top our
study was actually in third line
patients mcrpc patients and those
patients were pre-screened for not only
disease progression but the prevalence
of over or greater than five CTCs per
mil and as we showed earlier the
patients who tend to resist the air
targeted therapies and chemo therapies
that they tend to do hrd positive
patients tend to do worse on those
therapies and so there it's possible
that it's your enriching for these
patients in such a late stage setting
whereas I think the data we were shown
was much earlier in a first line setting
where these patients hadn't developed
resistance mechanisms to a our targeted
therapies or taxanes and and I think
that they had noticed or observed and
reported thirty-three percent prevalence
of hrd in this late stage and third line
we saw the prevalence of the markers
about forty percent so those very
similar numbers and then is the key to
this is that there were several patients
that were excluded from taupe Harbor
that were excluded because you couldn't
get tumor biopsy or you didn't see CTCs
and so when you think about that we're
not excluding patients if they didn't
have CTCs they were biomarker negative
and so I think this is some of the
highlights really some of the advantages
of a liquid biopsy but also highlights
some of these
vantages of using the phenotypic
analysis and compared us into genomic
sequencing thank you look like we have
time for one last question what is the
impact of heterogeneity on the stage
accuracy yeah and I think this is really
critical not only to this marker but
also just across all metastatic disease
and late stage disease and so as we
showed that there's a high degree of
heterogeneity in these patients and do
much worse on the targeted therapies but
when you think about it in the context
of hrd we saw sub clonal populations of
hrd present in a lot of the patients who
showed some response and so these
patients when you think about the under
sampling that can happen with the tissue
biopsy and other complications
associated with there being multiple sub
clonal drivers and that effect on an
interpretation of the sequencing results
you what you can see is that it's likely
to have an impact in selecting these
patients and so I think the single-cell
resolution of this and the ability to
look at the cells both phenotypically
and genotypically at the single-cell
level is really what's driving the
selection of these patients who may be a
sub clonal disease and could show some
response to the parp inhibitor versus
missing these patients due to sampling
air or having the heterogeneity to too
high that they can't see the signal in
the tumor biopsy and so I yeah I think
that's any other questions or well now I
just wanted to know use your final
comments for today's presentations yeah
and so you know we will address any
additional questions so please feel free
to shoot additional questions in we
presented this data I think it asmo we
have it up on the website we're happy to
discuss further or dive deeper into this
if there's an interest and and so i
think is follow-up but you know if you
if you go ahead and submit a question
we'll get back to you individually and
and we also really look forward to the
future path for this and as we expand
the applications they use you know
obviously parp inhibitors are growing
class of drugs they're being used quite
readily in new indications such as
prostate cancer squamous non-small cell
type indications I think that we're
getting a biopsy is very difficult and
very heterogeneous disease has been
observed so I think it's very exciting
how we can apply this marker going
forward well thank you again among
lenders for your awesome presentation i
also want to thank our sponsors epic
sciences for making today's educational
web path possible today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through februari of 2017 you'll receive
an email from lab boots alerting the
wings webcast will be available for
replay we invite you the core that
announcements to your colleagues who
have made of missed debate live event
until next time goodbye